often a story is only as good as its
villain Star Wars has Darth Vader jaws
has its shark Chicken Run has Mrs Tweedy
but climate change and are in action on
it don't have a clear mustache twirling
villain both the problem and our
response to it are deeply embedded in
modern society with Myriad individuals
making small choices that all got us to
where we are today
but if you demanded a villain someone to
point to when explaining why we are
facing a perilously warming Planet then
at least According to some people your
man is John sunanu
[Music]
in a previous video we discussed the
long history of climate science from the
discovery of carbon dioxide in 1757 to
the release of An Inconvenient Truth in
2006 something that was very clear in
that video was that the science of
climate and how it changes over time was
really well understood by the 1970s
academics such as the giant Roger Ravel
and the dedicated experimentalist
Charles Keeling published reports on the
threat of a planet's rapidly warming due
to a buildup of carbon dioxide in its
atmosphere so did scientists working in
the fossil fuel industry humble oil the
predecessor to Exxon published work on
carbon emissions changing the climate in
1957. but perhaps no one understood the
science better than James Edward Hansen
Hanson came from a humble background in
Iowa and fell in love with maths and
physics at an early age one night while
observing a lunar eclipse his
observations were ruined by the Moon
being totally obscured by a dust cloud a
dust cloud that Hansen later identified
came from the eruption of Mount agung on
the other side of the world Karen
married by an atmospheric current from
that point on Hansen under the tutelage
of space scientist James Van Allen
became interested in planetary
atmospheres specifically Venus and why
it was so incredibly hot he studied the
physics of why planets are the
temperatures they are and the greenhouse
effect which we covered previously when
NASA expanded their study at the Earth's
atmosphere Hanson was brought on board
to build computer models based on the
physics he had studied he became
particularly interested in how the
earth's climate had changed over recent
history and what was causing it he
demonstrated that according to the
equations while the majority of the
warming Trend was from increasing CO2
this wasn't enough to explain observed
changes on its own but if you took a
simple computer model of the physics of
the Earth's atmosphere and ocean and
varied CO2 added volcanic eruptions and
added small changes in the sun's output
you've got a pretty good explanation of
changing temperatures if you made the
model a bit more complex a bit more
realistic you got an even better results
as shown in the bottom right figure
science had a very good explanation for
why the Earth was warming while
volcanoes and the sun were factors
Hanson had accounted for these and found
that the warming was largely due to
increasing concentrations of CO2 in the
atmosphere caused by humans burning
fossil fuels Hansen would present this
science to some of the most powerful men
and women in the world but in the end
this figure would be used as a weapon
yielded in bad faith against Hansen and
against science and in the end against
the Earth
[Music]
in 1979 Hansen dialed into a meeting in
Cape Cod to discuss the changing climate
the meeting had been requested by
President Carter in the aftermath of a
government report that found atmospheric
CO2 concentrations would double by 2035
and that the world would warm by between
2 and 3 degrees Celsius as a result
Carter wanted to know if other top
scientists agreed with this finding as
such climatology Professor Jewel Charney
gathered together top Minds including
Hansen who over the course of several
days concluded that depending on how sea
ice responded to a planet with double
the concentration of CO2 the Earth would
warm on average by 3 degrees Celsius
with an era of one and a half degrees
either way the Charney report was a
serious warning and it sparked
discussions at the highest level so the
following year another meeting was
called this time in Florida and this
time involving scientists but also
economists policy experts and an expert
from industry their goal was to provide
the national Commission on air quality
with policy recommendations to prevent
this global warming from taking place
what could the government do to fix this
problem
the conversation was pragmatic everyone
was on the same page with the science
and agreed that this was a political
problem now but as politicians concern
themselves with problems as long as
their term length never more than a few
years the scientists would have to take
the lead in making recommendations for
long-term policy they agreed some kind
of international treaty would be
necessary to limit the accumulation of
CO2 in the atmosphere while the USA was
the largest emitter of CO2 action in
isolation wouldn't accomplish much but
if the USA demonstrated leadership and
took action first perhaps the rest of
the world would follow and maybe an
international agreement would too Henry
Shaw the representative from Exxon
canceled that a transition period would
be necessary with the world gradually
stopping the burning of fossil fuels and
starting to use renewable energy instead
Anne-Marie crocheti a public health
scholar from the national Commission on
air quality summarized the consensus
opinion as we got ourselves a bunch of
experts and by God they all endorsed
this point of view and think it's very
important they have disagreements about
the details of this and that but they
feel that it behooves us to intervene at
this point and try to prevent it yet on
the final day of the conference when all
these experts sat down to agree on a
statement to prevent it they ran into a
problem
in the first paragraph describing that
climatic changes were likely to occur
there were differences of opinion
williker proposed John lauman the
Stanford engineer what about the words
highly likely to occur asked Anthony
Scoville from the house science
committee Almost sure said David Rose
the nuclear engineer for nit almost
surely said lauman perhaps you can use
will occur said another and quantify the
changes when they start to quantify the
changes said lamb and I can't make such
a statement changes as yet of a little
understood or extremely likely almost
surely to occur this went on for hours
the group never made it to policy
recommendations they never even made it
to the second paragraph of their
statement the political problem remained
open and then four days after the
meeting ended President Reagan was
elected
I mentioned in the previous video that
the Reagan years were tumultuous for the
study of climate change to say that the
Reagan Administration was not a fan of
environment mental research and
regulation was putting it mildly when
Reagan entered the White House the
Environmental Protection Agency or EPA
had its staff numbers cut in half when
the Council on Environmental Quality
published a report warning that fossil
fuel use could permanently and
disastrously alter the Earth's
atmosphere Reagan declined to act on the
advice instead he considered eliminating
the council plans were floated to close
the energy Department increased coal
production and deregulate surface coal
mining instead the Reagan White House
was not interested in human impacts on
the climate it simply didn't factor into
their political calculations but the U.S
Congress was getting an education on how
humans were changing the planet courtesy
of James Hansen and representative Al
Gore we met Gore previously while he
studied at Harvard under Roger Ravel
after winning his third term as
Congressman for Tennessee Gore was made
chairman of an oversight committee
within the science committee a position
regarded as a Backwater within a
Backwater but one he was determined to
use to raise awareness of scientific and
environmental issues as such he invited
Roger Ravel to testify before Congress
in 1980 on the seriousness of man-made
climate change but he made little impact
Congress just wasn't interested in what
they considered a hypothetical so a
Gore's invitation Hanson testified in
1982 describing his work identifying a
warming signal in the temperature record
Hansen and the other experts testifying
that day including Melvin Calvin who had
won a Nobel Prize for his work on the
carbon cycle agreed there was more than
enough evidence to Merit action on
carbon emissions changing the national
model of energy production away from
fossil fuels some of the few congressmen
present agreed when asked by a
representative when such action would
need to take Place Hanson simply said
very soon Calvin said it was useless
waiting for stronger evidence of warming
quote it is already later than you think
but while handsome was building momentum
and changing the first few Minds in the
US Congress the White House was unmoved
in fact in 1980 three it doubled down on
its position and it did so thanks to a
new comprehensive report titled changing
climate this new report was the result
of the 1978 climate act signed by
previous president Carter part of the
ACT stipulated that a committee should
be put together to comprehensively
investigate how changing carbon dioxide
levels would affect the climate the
heads of this committee was to be bill
nirenberg
nirenberg was a nuclear physicist who
had spent part of his PhD working on the
Manhattan Project after that he'd become
an esteemed professor of physics at UC
Berkeley and expanded his interests to
include research on National Defense and
the natural environment in 1965 when
Revel retired as the head of the Scripps
oceanographic Institute he was asked to
take on the role and threw himself into
the science the even intervened
personally when research funding for
keeling's carbon dioxide monitoring
project was threatened Nuremberg was
dedicated to the science and a Natural
Choice to chair such a report he pulled
together a superstar team of scientists
and economists including William Nord
House of Yale and Thomas shelling of
Harvard they spent five years
investigating the issue and in 83
published their conclusions the
scientific content of the report
concurred with the Charlie report a few
years earlier CO2 doubling was likely to
happen in the mid 21st century and this
would warm the planet by between one and
a half and four and a half degrees
Celsius but potentially three times that
much over the polar regions this would
affect whether agriculture and the
ecosystems all over the world this was a
problem the scientists said and we
shouldn't simply wait and see what
happens as such the synthesis of the
report recommended the situation was one
of concern a not of panic and no
immediate action was necessary wait what
you see the report contained five
chapters written by scientists and two
written by economists the five
scientific chapters lined up with the
Charney report and other academic papers
the two economic chapters approached the
problem from a different angle they
assumed that any serious impacts of
climate change were so far into the
future as to be discountable that is to
say a dollar today is worth more than a
dollar tomorrow and a lot more than a
dollar in a century so you could
discount costs far into the future
nordhaus wrote that while the obvious
solution in the present was a carbon tax
this would be hard to implement and thus
not worth doing michelleing suggested
that adapting to a change in climate and
treating the symptoms Next Century would
be cheaper and easier than addressing
the root cause no regulatory policy
could possibly succeed so climate change
is what we should expect I'm sure I
don't need to point out this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy to quote Naomi
rescues and Eric Conway writing much
later in merchants of doubt this was
like suggesting that researchers
shouldn't try to cure cancer because
that would be too expensive and in any
case people in the future might decide
that dying from cancer is not so bad in
fact I just want to read a brief quote
from shelling which I found particularly
telling of his economic approach he
wrote today little of our gross domestic
product is produced outdoors and
therefore little is susceptible to
climate Agriculture and Forestry are
less than three percent of total output
and little else is much affected even if
agricultural productivity declined by a
third over the next half century the per
capita GNP we might have achieved by
2050 would still achieve in 2051
considering that agricultural
productivity in most parts of the world
continues to improve and that many crops
May benefit directly from enhanced
photosynthesis due to increased carbon
dioxide side note this is absolutely not
true I made a whole video about it it is
not at all certain that the net impact
on agriculture will be negative or much
noticed in the developed world this
statement seems remarkable naive today
if shelling had talked to pretty much
any historian about past climatic
changes and their impacts or considered
anywhere other than America or given any
value to biodiversity or geopolitical
impacts of less food being available he
would have known that this was
hopelessly narrow-minded a warming
climate doesn't just affect GMP it
doesn't just affect the developed world
and it certainly doesn't just affect
humans and you'd think these points
would be reflected in the summary or
that nirenberg's background as a
scientist would make him give more
weight to the five scientific chapters
in his conclusions yep his summary of
the report the only part that was
actually read and disseminated in the
Press cited heavily with the economists
it did not deny that the situation the
facts existed but questioned the
interpretation of those facts as a
problem if it goes the way we think the
summary read it'll be manageable in the
next hundred or so years
according to historians of science
including oreskis and Conway much of
that position came down to nirenberg
we haven't seen the last of him in this
story
the report was criticized at the time
reviewers including legendary physicist
Alvin Weinberg wrote that the report was
so seriously flawed in its underlying
analysis and in its conclusions that he
hardly knew where to begin physicist and
later director of the Scripps
oceanographic Institute Edward Freeman
said of the scientific community in
retrospect we knew the report was
garbage so we just ignored it but the
Reagan Administration did no such thing
it grasped the changing climate report
with both hands and used it to bat away
any calls for government policy on
climate it was used to counter two
further reports from the EPA on cold use
damaging the climate which were
described as alarmist the White House
was not budging but more and more
scientists were making noise and
recommending immediate action at gaul's
invitation Hanson testified before
Congress again in 1984 and made more of
an impact more representatives were
starting to take the science on board in
1985 a meeting of scientists of the
United Nations environment program and
the World Meteorological organization in
vilak Austria issued a formal report
stating that while some warming of the
planet was now inevitable the extent of
the disaster could be profoundly
affected by aggressive coordinated
government policy scientists who had
previously been on the fence of
advocating for immediate government
intervention including Roger Revell
declared that it was time to begin a
radical shift in energy production away
from fossil fuels it was a small but
growing number of scientists and some
politicians against the administration
of the most powerful country on Earth
which felt it had the science on its
side the fight seemed woefully
unbalanced but that year the scales of
power were tipped and a path forward
presented when a hole was discovered
over Antarctica
the Earth's atmosphere contains a lot of
oxygen mostly in molecules made of two
oxygen atoms but sometimes high energy
light from the sun splits those
molecules apart into individual oxygen
atoms in the middle atmosphere these
individual atoms rapidly latch onto
whatever molecule is nearest often
that's another oxygen molecule and the
result is a new molecule made of three
oxygen atoms ozone ozone is not too
stable and so is eventually destroyed by
natural processes that are approximately
in balance with the forces that create
it the result is a band of ozone
approximately 15 to 35 kilometers above
the surface that we call the ozone layer
though it's not really a layer that
concentration smoothly varies in
altitude like this for lack of a better
term though the ozone layer is extremely
important to life on Earth because it
has two different Atomic bonds ozone
absorbs ultraviolet radiation from the
Sun in a way that normal oxygen
molecules don't if this ultraviolet
radiation were to reach the surface it
would cause the breakdown of cell
membranes in the living beings and have
various Health impacts including cancer
the ozone layer then is like our
planetary defense Shield against
ultraviolet radiation
in the 1970s however it was discovered
that chemicals called
chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs used in
spray cans and in refrigerators were
disrupting the processes that maintained
the ozone layer the total amount of
ozone in the atmosphere was decreasing
but in 1985 something much Starker was
revealed a hole in the ozone layer over
Antarctica an extreme decrease in the
ozone concentration that formed in the
southern hemisphere's winter during
which the planet's surface was
effectively blasted by UV radiation and
this ozone hole was growing the world's
government's mobilized rapidly in 1986 a
senate hearing takes place where
scientists convinced Senators that
policy was needed to ban the use of CFCs
and prevent them leaking to the ozone
layer President Reagan was
unsurprisingly against such policy but
after Dupont by far the largest producer
of CFCs realized that they could profit
from the transition to replacement
chemicals and so lobbied the president
to enact policy as soon as possible
Reagan in endorsed an international
treaty to phase out use of CFCs in 1987
then just two years after the ozone hole
was identified the Montreal protocol was
agreed a binding International treaty
that phased out the use of ozone
destroying chemicals and describing into
the future for a moment it was extremely
effective at fixing the problem current
projections suggest the ozone layer will
return to 1980 Levels by the mid 21st
century the campaign to protect the
ozone layer demonstrated that the
International Community could rapidly
come together and agree on a course of
action and a set of government policies
to protect the environment climate
scientists watching at the time saw this
and were galvanized look they said it
could be done there's a path forwards
and there's still time what we need is a
binding treaty like the Montreal
protocol for carbon emissions in fact
the 1986 Senate hearing on ozone was
actually a joint hearing with Scientists
speaking about both ozone depletion and
climate change on the first day the
ozone problem was discussed with a
flickering animation of the growing hole
over the Antarctic that gripped the room
and dominated news coverage that
guaranteed a packed out hearing room on
the second day for the discussion of
climate change which For Better or For
Worse the public now associated with
ozone depletion Hanson again spoke of
the overwhelming scientific evidence but
this time politicians were on board too
now Senator Gore underlined the
scientific consensus the need for more
research was mocked by Senators on both
sides of the aisle Republican senator
John Chaffee requested that the state
department begin negotiations on a
global climate Accord with the Soviet
Union immediately momentum was building
specific National policies were gaining
support including a carbon tax initially
suggested back in 83 by nordhaus the
next year there were eight days of
climate-related hearings in both
chambers of Congress a National Climate
Change strategy was introduced the
preparing for climate change conference
in Washington DC was attended by top
politicians representatives from the
fossil fuel industry and scientists
alike Mikhail bodico Soviet
climatologist gave a lesson on climate
change to the children of U.S senators
present naturally Hanson was there too
presenting his research and taking in
the carnival-like atmosphere it felt
like this was the start of a solution
the start of a new partnership between
government Science and Industry
but that was exactly what some people
were afraid of
while this video is largely focused on
America in the late 20th century it is
impossible to ignore the global
political context of these events
America was locked in an ideological
struggle throughout the 70s and 80s and
indeed the 20th century with the Soviet
Union on the one side you had the idea
that free markets and capitalism were
the best way to improve people's lives
and on the other the decentralized
planned socialist state was the best way
to do this not everybody believed the
world fell into this strict dichotomy
but there were hardliners on both sides
who certainly did within the United
States there were individuals who saw
socialism as evil this built on work
such as capitalism and freedom which
argued that economic freedom interpreted
to mean free markets was a necessary
precondition to political freedom in
other words according to these
hardliners any government meddling in
society was the first step on the
slippery slope to an authoritarian
system such as practiced by the Soviet
Union this is much too complex to do
justice in this video but suffice to say
there was a significant overlap between
individuals with this economic opinion
those with technological or scientific
backgrounds and particularly those who
worked on projects around National
Defense in America in the second half of
the 20th century such individuals
included Robert jastrow and Fred's Seitz
scientists who had some involvement in
the Cold War against the Soviet Union
and who both passionately believed that
the Soviet system was to be avoided at
all costs to that end sites and chastro
founded the George C Marshall Institute
in 1984 to defend the Reagan
administration's planned Strategic
Defense Initiative a high-tech system to
intercept Soviet nuclear weapons before
they could reach their targets it was so
high-tech in fact that the necessary
Technologies didn't exist yet they still
don't but jastro and sites railed
against scientists who pointed this out
despite being scientists themselves
their political beliefs took precedence
over the scientific evidence the Soviet
Union was a threat that must be must be
haunted they
place in 1987 they warned that the
Soviet Union would become so powerful in
five years that they could take over the
world when the Soviet Union collapsed
four years later then you might think
that the Institute would be left without
purpose but by that point they had
already pivoted to a new threat on
Liberty people trying to prevent climate
change Anthropologist Margaret Mead
wrote of the unfolding climate crisis in
1975 that never before have the
governing bodies of the world been faced
with decisions so far reaching it is
inevitable that there will be a clash
between those concerned with immediate
problems and those who concern
themselves with long-term consequences
while to most of us this was a sensible
declaration based on science and
advocating for policy Beyond term limits
to those hardliners who advocated for
free markets and small government this
sounded like the marching of Jack Boots
the sound of authoritarianism
and both sites and jastro had done this
before despite clear scientific evidence
around the dangers of smoking they had
campaigned against government policy to
restrict smoking indoors or in public
spaces they had campaigned against
policy to prevent acid rain by limiting
sulfate emissions they'd even campaigned
against the Banning of ozone depleting
chemicals like CFCs after all any new
government intervention was the start of
the slippery slope towards communism in
each case the Playbook was the same
discredit the science disseminate false
information spread confusion and above
all promote doubt and they were funded
handsomely to do so by whatever
Industries stood to profit from a lack
of government intervention this time it
was fossil fuel-based companies such as
Exxon who wanted to keep profiting from
the continued use of oil gas and coal
previously Exxon and other entities like
the American petroleum Institute have
actively funded research on climate
change and had conceded that legislation
limiting the use of their products was
probably going to happen as such they
wanted to be part of the solution which
was why Henry Shaw was present at the
meeting in Florida but at roughly the
same time as the founding of the George
C Marshall Institute the industry
changed Tech they started funding
misinformation campaigns muddying the
waters citing uncertainties in the
science as a reason to delay action and
keep burning oil
but some of that uncertainty was
engineered
because Seitz and jastro were not alone
in founding the George C Marshall
Institute and not alone in their attack
on climate change policy
there was a third founder who retired
from the Scripps oceanographic Institute
to join the board of directors and that
was Bill nirenberg
back in 1978 nirenberg heard about the
National Climate act and lobbied to form
a committee to produce a report on the
state of climate research as part of the
ACT he was elected to be the committee
head and he elected members to the
committee who shared his views such as
nordhaus and shelling perhaps it's no
surprise then that the report they
released in 83 counseled for no changes
in government policy or that the
synthesis of the report cited so heavily
with the wait and see economists but
with the establishment of the George C
Marshall Institute in 1984 this was a
Prelude of what was to come The
Institute and other well-connected
organizations like it were influencing
men and women at the highest level of
government telling them to not listen to
the scientists and not do anything about
limiting emissions of carbon dioxide on
the one hand you had a growing number of
increasingly vocal scientists and
bipartisan support for an international
agreement on climate change on the other
you had a very small but very well
connected group of free market
absolutists
the fight see quite unbalanced and the
stage was set for the late 80s to become
the Battleground for the future of our
climate
1988 was a scorching year in the United
States on the hottest June 23rd in the
history of Washington DC Hanson
testified once more before the U.S
Senate this time the swelteringly hot
room was packed and Hanson did not mince
his words the warming signal of
human-caused climate change was already
here he said it could be detected with
99 confidence and while 88 was probably
going to be the warmest year on record
it was only going to get worse he
presented three projections of future
warming once again two gaze into the
future the middle realistic one of these
has been almost exactly borne out over
the past three decades and senators in
1988 listened Senator Max baucus from
Montana called for the UN environment
program to begin preparing a global
remedy to the problem Senator Dale
bumpers from Arkansas emphasized that
the Press should be covering this you in
every newspaper in America which they
did while called by Senator Tim worth
the hearing became known as the Hanson
hearing and together with the success of
the Montreal protocol the previous year
it gave even more hope to an
international agreement on carbon
emissions being achieved but
should such an agreement the next
Montreal protocol aim to achieve at a
meeting in Toronto of scientists and
politicians Senator Wirth suggested a 20
reduction in emissions by the year 2000
while 20 by 2000 was a nice catchphrase
it was a little Rich for some
politicians blood so the target was
amended to be a 20 reduction by 2005.
this became known as the Toronto goal by
the end of the year 32 climate bills
were introduced in Congress the biggest
of which proposed by worth called for
that Toronto goal and for the creation
of a global agreement on emissions by
1992. even President Reagan seemed to
have changed his stance when he signed
an agreement with Soviet Premier
Gorbachev that included a pledge to
cooperate on climate change
internationally West Germany's
Parliament created a special Commission
on climate change and recommended action
beyond the Toronto girl calling for a 30
reduction in emissions Sweden's
Parliament announced a strategy to
freeze emissions at the 1988 level and
introduce a carbon tax UK prime minister
Margaret Thatcher spoke at the Royal
Society in London of the need to combat
label warming and the UN unanimously
endorsed the establishment of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc the momentum seemed
Unstoppable especially when George Bush
Senior was elected as U.S president that
year on the campaign Trail he described
himself as an environmentalist those who
think we are powerless to do anything
about the greenhouse effect Bush said
are forgetting about the White House
Effect two weeks after the election he
was visited by former presidents Carter
and Ford who recommended making climate
change policy a national priority and
doubling the epa's research budget an
emissions Target and even a carbon tax
seemed inevitable in a year or two
but
in 1989 under the name of the George C
Marshall Institute nirenberg sites and
jastro circulated an unpublished white
paper published the following year as a
small book titled global warming what
does the science tell us its contents
followed the same Playbook as the
author's previous activities around
secondhand smoke acid rain and CFC
emissions they were manufacturing doubt
in particular they claimed that global
warming wasn't taking place due to
emissions of carbon dioxide but rather
due to changes in the sun they argued
using Sunspot and tree ring data that
the sun had entered a period of slightly
higher energy output in the 19th century
and this was responsible for the warming
to date seeing as the sun went through
in approximately 200 year cycle they
said the warming was almost over and
things would soon cool down by contrast
blaming changes in CO2 just didn't make
sense and look they had proof
this was a figure from none other than
James Hansen showing that there was
little correlation between CO2 and
temperature and the scientists like
Hansen would try to push an agenda by
not considering the sun look the lines
don't even match up
of course this was only part of the
figure Hanson produced the rest you've
already seen
the complete figure clearly demonstrated
that in order to explain recent warming
you need to account for changes in CO2
and volcanoes and changes in solar
activity but you could not explain 20th
century warming without changes in CO2
because there were no meaningful changes
in solar output something that
scientists like Hansen but also many
others had already included in their
models there is simply no way that a
scientist of nirenberg's caliber did not
know what he was doing by only including
the top left part of this figure in
isolation
only the simpler model and only one
factor it was blatant misrepresentation
of the science
but he wasn't content to stop there the
George C Marshall Institute paper also
claimed that there was doubt among the
scientific Community as to the
seriousness of global warming anyway
citing studies in the early 80s that
reached different conclusions of course
Nuremberg was referencing differences in
conclusions between the Charney reports
and many other reports from scientists
and the 1983 changing climate report
that he wrote
but this was just one as yet unpublished
paper standing separate from the
overwhelming number of Publications from
scientists and policy experts how much
of a difference could it really make
well when the George C Marshall
Institute contacts the White House and
nirenberg gives a briefing to
presidential staff himself
it could make a big difference
here is where we catch up to white house
chief of staff John sunanu
sunanu was a mechanical engineer by
training getting his PhD from MIT and
teaching at Tufts University for over a
decade before moving into politics he
became governor of New Hampshire before
being selected as George Bush senior's
Chief of Staff in 1989. he was present
for the briefing by nirenberg and was
particularly taken by his arguments in
fact sununu had quite similar political
beliefs to nirenberg conservative
technocratic anti-tax he suspected that
scientists working on climate change
were part of some nefarious
authoritarian cabal since the mid 70s
and Margaret Mead's statement and in
nirenberg's briefing his suspicions were
confirmed a single document pushed him
over the edge into outright hostility
towards climate scientists the bush
white house now had a breakaway
anti-climate science faction led by
sununu this first became apparent at the
first meetings of the ipcc in 1989.
President Bush's new head of the EPA
William K Riley argued that this was the
perfect opportunity to show the world
the Bush Administration was serious
about climate change and proposed a
global Accord to produce carbon
emissions sunanu now disagreed in fact
he forbade U.S delegates going to the
meeting in Geneva from making any such
commitments on a mission reduction at
the meeting at this point the U.S was
the only Western Country on record
opposing such action that may have been
it but just Days Later Hanson was due to
give another briefing to the U.S Senate
this time clarifying the science around
climate change modifying extreme
rainfall events Hanson forwarded his
pre-prepared statement to NASA who
forwarded it to the White House for
approval this was standard procedure for
these hearings on matters of science it
was just a formality but this time the
White House demanded changes an
anonymous sensor wanted him to say that
the causes of global warming were
scientifically unknown and might be
attributable to natural processes he was
also asked to demand that Congress only
consider climate legislation that would
immediately benefit the economy
independent of concerns about an
increase in greenhouse effect Hanson was
taken aback and unsure what to do with
this he didn't want to make such
obviously flawed statements but was no
politician so asked Senator Gore for
advice Gore with Hanson's permission
broke the story to the press and caused
an outrage politicians and newspapers
alike proclaimed that the White House or
a faction within it was censoring
science Gore got a personal apology from
the White House who then scrambled to
save face the ipcc meeting was still
happening in Eva so as part of damage
control sununu sent a message to U.S
negotiators reversing his previous
stance now the U.S should work to
develop full International consensus on
necessary steps to prepare for formal
treaty negotiating process
well the immediate public reaction was
wanted relief policy experts saw through
this as mere waffle and predictably
nothing was agreed in Geneva hopes were
pinned instead on the next meeting
the big one where the world's
environment ministers would come
together in nordwick in the Netherlands
to endorse the ipcc process and it was
hoped hoped by world leaders including
Margaret Thatcher that this was where a
binding treaty was going to happen the
U.S in theory was still on board but
sunanu was still not happy about it with
things moving so quickly he took it upon
himself to study the physics of climate
further and so asked for a very simple
one-dimensional model of the Earth's
atmosphere to be installed on his
personal computer at the White House
based on playing with this very simple
model he decided that Hansen's models
and indeed all the state-of-the-art's
three-dimensional models built by actual
climate scientists were technical
poppycock there was no way you could use
such models to claim the climate was
changing or why when during a meeting a
junior staffer mentioned in passing an
initiative to reduce fossil fuel use
soon interrupted her asking why would
you want to do that
because of climate change she replied
sunanu went non-linear I don't want
anyone in this Administration without a
scientific background using climate
change or global warming ever again if
you don't have a technical basis for
policy don't run around making decisions
on the basis of newspaper headlines
[Music]
PA director Riley was in the room at the
time and sensed this was really directed
at him his relationship with sunanu was
becoming increasingly strained as the
latter thought the former wasn't
scientific enough as such Riley was to
be accompanied to the nordwick
conference by Bush's science advisor and
sununu appointee Alan Bromley the pair
flew to the Netherlands the Dutch hosts
had gathered senior diplomats from 68
Nations to agree to the Toronto goal
reducing emissions by 20 by 2005. most
delegates apparently turned up expecting
everyone to Simply sign the agreement
but the negotiations in nordwick ran
long they ran until close to Dawn
actually when the Swedish environment
Minister ducked out of the conference
room for a bathroom break in the middle
of the night he was asked by American
activists outside for an update
why is it taking so long they asked your
government he said angrily is this thing
up
The Binding International agreement on
carbon emissions was torpedoed by
Bromley who had convinced the UK the
Soviet Union and Japan to abandon the
Toronto goal along with the United
States they wanted more wiggle room and
no binding Target there was just too
much uncertainty in the science they
said a line that would have been fed to
them by Bromley who was instructed to
tell them by sunanu
later analysis estimated that if the
nordwick agreement had gone ahead with
the Toronto goal it could have held
global warming to less than one and a
half degrees Celsius in his 2018 account
of the events leading up to the
conference losing Earth Nathaniel rich
places the blame for this missed
opportunity squarely at John sununu's
feet he is the villain you're looking
for but is that fair sununu was almost
certainly the reason Bromley convinced
the British Japanese and Soviets to not
sign The Binding agreement but he only
held such a Hardline position because of
the George C Marshall Institute report
and the briefing he was given by Bill
nirenberg and besides there were plenty
of further opportunities for climate
action after sununu resigned in disgrace
in 1991 after using government Jets to
go skiing and golfing no seriously as
Riley pointed out in an interview in
losing Earth sununu's obstruction was
critical at a time when public support
for climate policy was at an all-time
high and there was little coordinated
opposition to such policy but the
negotiation of the first ipcc Accord
continued until 1992 in Rio and
President Bush especially after the
collapse of the Soviet Union leaving
America as the only superpower could
have demanded and probably got a binding
treaty at any point in the negotiations
and this was with Bromley who had grown
increasingly supportive of climate
policy after nordwick acting as his
chief scientist but Bush wasn't
interested also had the Toronto goal
been agreed on in a binding treaty at
Nordic or elsewhere would it have been
achieved the Technologies necessary to
decarbonize the global economy were
largely in their infancy in 1989. even
if politicians were serious about
sticking to the goal was it actually
possible politically or technologically
the fact is as sununu himself points out
in an interview in losing Earth world
leaders at that time wanted to look like
they took the issue seriously but didn't
want to actually do enough to fix the
problem a situation you could argue
continues to this day
it is not accurate to say that John
sununu is the reason we Face a world
with 2 degrees Celsius of warming the
history of climate change is much more
complex than that but there was a brief
window of a few years when the
scientific understanding was strong
there was Global political momentum and
misinformation campaigns by the George C
Marshall Institute and other
organizations had not yet kicked into
high well-financed gear and politicized
the issue as they did in the 90s by the
time of President Clinton the issue of
climate policy was the darling of the
political left and the enemy of the
political rights in the most powerful
country on Earth
in the late 80s there was a hope for a
binding International agreement that
could have radically changed the
trajectory of the 21st century and
beyond limiting us to less than one and
a half degrees of global warming
but I hope so weak that in the end it
took a single man to Snuff it out
does that make him more or less
of a villain thank you
at its heart this story is about science
science informing our knowledge of the
climate emergency and influencing how we
respond to it as we've seen a lack of
specialist scientific knowledge can
prevent you from acting appropriately
when faced with a scientific problem and
in fact lead you to be manipulated by
people with an agenda having basic
knowledge of the scientific process and
Concepts like statistics and logic is
incredibly valuable and can open new
doors for you this is of course why we
teach those subjects in school but
that's not a process that everyone is
receptive to perhaps you struggled or
struggled in science classes and would
appreciate a personal learning coach to
help you in those subjects ideally this
coach would make the process fast
enjoyable and never leave you feeling
like you don't understand well that's
exactly what brilliant.org does and
Brilliant have been kind enough to
sponsor this video brilliant has 1000
thousands of lessons from foundational
and advanced maths to physics data
science neural networks and much more
with new lessons added monthly of
particular relevance to the story in
this video they actually have a lesson
on solar energy this lesson and the
thousands of others on brilliant.org are
interactive something shown in studies
to be six times more effective than just
watching lecture content and causing
students to retain information and
something that I personally really value
I really wish that brilliant existed
when I was in full-time education to try
everything brilliant has to offer free
for a full 30 days visit brilliant.org
Simon Clark or click the link in the
description the first 200 of you to do
so will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription that's
brilliant.org Simon Clark with thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
for being well brilliant
this video was almost entirely based on
two books merchants of Doubt by Naomi
oreski's and Eric Conway and losing
Earth by Nathaniel Rich if you found the
topic of this video interesting and in
particular the role of men like
jastrocytes and Nuremberg spreading
doubt in science I implore you to read
them they're both excellent and both
Linked In the description the style of
this video and the previous one were
heavily influenced by Bobby broccoli and
John Boyce so do check them and their
amazing videos out I want to thank Bobby
broccoli for his technical support in
making these videos and thank the lovely
people whose names are on screen right
now they are my executive producers over
on patreon.com forward slash Simon oxfiz
and make videos like this one possible
if you would like to see more videos
like this one please consider pledging
on my patreon also linked in the
description please also let me know in
the comments and if you enjoyed the
video please do pop it a like and share
it with other people who may be
interested it this is a shocking story
and one that I think everyone should
know about
that just leads me to say thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next